all of the legal issues that we've had
going on she's heard about and she's
dealing with it in her own way Julian
Savannah Chrisley revealed ten-year-old
Chloe is dealing with the family's legal
issues in her own way Chloe's really
nosy so she'll put on her headphones and
act like she's listening to something
when reality nothing's on so you think
she's listening when really she's just
listening to the conversation exactly
last week Julie and her husband Todd
Chrisley were sentenced to a combined 19
years in prison after they were
convicted of tax fraud in June but
before their sentencing the Chrisley
family matriarch joined Savannah on her
Podcast Unlocked and opened up about how
her adopted daughter was handling the
drama she listens more than
you think yeah and those kids do yeah
most kids do most kids you know my
parents we think you know they don't
hear an argument or a concern or
whatever but kids hear everything Chloe
is the biological daughter of Todd's son
Kyle from a previous relationship
hello how are you the devil ah Chloe
Todd and Julie obtained custody of Chloe
in 2016 amid Kyle's struggles with
addiction we have had her since she was
a little less than a year old this child
came to us from her biological mother
and she had been starved half the time
she wasn't clean she came to us one time
with a burn on her chest and we had to
take her to the pediatrician and
Savannah noted that people have a lot to
say online anytime she calls Chloe her
sister I don't care what you say about
me but if you come at my kids or you
come about my wife oh gosh then I'm
gonna drag you she has been adopted she
is ours she is our daughter which makes
her your sister she said you know when I
grow up I want to be just like my sister
and I said why do you want to be like
sassy she says because she is a good
person daddy the two add that they wish
the haters would focus on the positive I
consider it a blessing
your relationship with Chloe and how
much you love her and how much she loves
you and how she views you as her big
sister and and that is a blessing not
something that people should have try to
tear down right yeah it's crazy now the
Chrisley family Dynamics are changing
yet again last week a judge sentenced
Todd to 12 years in prison as well as 16
months probation and Julie seven years
in prison plus 16 months probation we
signed up for a show that has
entertained millions and millions and
millions of people but what we didn't
sign up for is to be lied on shortly
before the couple received their
sentences Savannah reflected on the
possibility of her parents going to jail
and becoming the legal guardian to Chloe
and her brother Grayson I come home
Tuesday and
I have custody of a 16 year old and a 10
year old and we spend our first
Thanksgiving not as a family but
Savannah told E.T just days prior to her
parents sentencing that the family was
staying strong they're pushing through
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith
[Music]